the bear not only runs like a working
restaurant behind the scenes but it
carries that same level of intensity and
stress that real life chefs and back of
house crew find difficult to watch you
might be surprised to find out that
every piece of food in the show was
actually real and prepared on set Jeremy
Allen White trained at Michelin star
restaurants and the season one finale
was shot in one continuous very
stressful 18 minute take everyone knows
the bear is an incredible show so
incredible that A-list actors were lined
up around the block trying to guest star
on it John Bernthal comes back for a
heartbreaking flashback Cameo as carmi's
late brother Michael who else struggled
a bit during the scene when carmy opens
up his locker for the first time we also
get to see Will Poulter teach Marcus
about desserts in Copenhagen which not
gonna lie made me really wonder what a
minty Snickers bar would would taste
like we also get the pleasure of seeing
the iconic Jamie Lee Curtis drive a car
through a house and like there are tons
of other guest stars too Sarah Polson
Molly Gordon Bob odenker John mullaney
Jillian Jacobs Robert Townsend and Joel
McHale you'd think Jeremy Allen White
was a true professional by the way he
portrays Carmi in the kitchen but in
reality the guy could really only make
scrambled eggs and toast so obviously he
had to do quite a bit of training for
this role he spent a lot of time working
at past Jolie in Santa Monica a Michelin
star restaurant and was apologizing up
and down to the staff because of how bad
he was I'm sorry I'm here too please be
patient with me at one point he got
instructed to cut some vegetables by a
new line cook he'd never met apparently
the vegetables didn't turn out too great
I told her you know what I'm an actor
I'm not a chef and she just goes no I
know it was just so painfully obvious he
had never stepped foot in a kitchen like
that before so speak taking a training
before he got to step into the actual
kitchen Jeremy Allen White and Iowa
debris had to take a two-week crash
course at The Institute of Culinary
education in Pasadena to get into their
characters they got really good with
their knife work Jeremy describes it as
repetition but there's no way he could
actually be a chef it would take many
more crash courses than just one but no
it wasn't natural yeah I'll say though
naturally his favorite part about
training and being in the kitchen was
the food he got to eat I ate a lot a lot
of hot dogs a lot of Italian beef dozens
ever since the show aired Jeremy's been
referred to as Chef quite a bit when he
went to one of of his favorite
restaurants in New York three days after
the show aired he was surprised by how
many yes chefs he got Jeff no Chef
you're welcome Chef when beforehand no
one really even paid attention to him
there a big part of the response was
because the show really connected to
people in the restaurant industry more
than the cast and crew thought it would
even to the point of it being difficult
to watch for some people I think the
show seems real to them they were trying
to show how tough the back of house
environment is for people in the
industry they kind of did it a little
too well I think it was a little bit
traumatizing for for some chefs to watch
you know we have to talk about it one
thing that's not lore accurate to a real
restaurant kitchen is how long and flowy
carmi's hair is after Jeremy Allen White
read a book by Marco Pierre White he was
inspired by how long his hair was on the
book's cover so he decided to grow his
out for the show as a little nod to him
soon after though everyone started
calling him out for the fact that he
should have been wearing a cap or a hair
in the kitchen so much of carmi's hair
it's probably in all those sandwiches
it's giving secret ingredient Maddie
Matheson who plays Fack on the show is
also a professional chef yes I am
because of every extensive experience in
the kitchen he worked as a technical
advisor on the show he was also joined
by Courtney store the showrunner sister
who is also a professional chef Jeremy
asked them to call him out if he was
ever doing anything goofy in the kitchen
please yell cut stop me and Maddie would
at the time a big part of why the show
looks and feels so real like you're
really in a restaurant kitchen it's
because of Maddie and Courtney's real
life experiences circling back on that
real life experience when Jeremy first
started training at these restaurants he
started out as a fly on the wall trying
not to be in anyone's way he studied the
movement of the chefs and kitchen staff
in order to emulate the way they moved
through the kitchen which would soon be
his set there's a real like ballet to
these kitchens and how everybody moves
because they're small he had to master
that before they shoved him onto the
actual line he shockingly prepared real
food that was Sir served to customers at
pastroli the kitchen that was used in
the pilot episode was an actual
restaurant kitchen for the rest of the
episodes they built an identical Kitchen
on a sound stage down to like the water
stains I still don't understand how they
did it literally everything in the
kitchen was real and operated like an
actual restaurant yes even the fire and
the plumbing all real even the food they
cooked was prepared on set in real time
they'd actually get in trouble a lot for
eating in between takes these are props
we know that this is like food that
looks good and smells good and whatever
if you've worked in a restaurant before
you know that it can be an absolute
nightmare apparently so I was doing a
show about one why hasn't there been a
restaurant show before in like on day
one we were like
why they established that if they could
capture only 50 of how chaotic a real
restaurant is they'd be in good shape it
helped that FX trusted them to do the
show even though they weren't exactly
sure how it would be done that is a
great question it also really helped and
made it a lot less nightmarish that the
show was incredibly intimate especially
coming out of covet experience of making
it was so incredible I didn't realize
how much I've missed like being with
people when it came to the props and the
set they wanted everything to look and
feel like a working business
particularly the business that was
depicted on screen they had to make sure
the crops were accurately placed for the
story being told Maddie Matheson had a
lot of input on the continuity and story
that the props told the guy literally in
the scene he didn't even get enough beef
why is there beef in the walking when
they first showed up there was a
plethora of ingredients in the walk-in
as well as too many pots and pans they
had to start stripping everything back
because essentially this restaurant
didn't have the funds for all that stuff
so we know the bear is a comedy but
sometimes it's downright stressful to
watch that comedic relief is essential a
lot of the quips and comedic beats were
naturally brought to life by the cast
what's UPS that's in Chicago uh United
Parcel Service every take was different
from the last and they had a lot of fun
going back and forth with each other a
big reason why the show's comedy is so
successful is because the cast they
really love each other to make it feel
that alive sort of invites weird funny
to happen the chemistry is prevalent in
every scene also because the Way It Was
Written was so fast and repetitive a lot
of the time it gave the actors a lot of
leeway to rip off of one another with
the lines that were written in the
script oftentimes they would ask to go
and do a take again because they were
having so much fun let the directors be
like nah we're good we got it the
episode the review was done in one 18
minute take it was done to hone in and
capture the cooker pressure
claustrophobia of the chaotic kitchen
setting the Creator Christopher Storer
utilized his background in in live stage
work like Bo Burnham specializes as well
as minimalist character-driven comedy
like rainy they ended up shrinking down
the script in that episode which
originally took place over several hours
into What was seen in the 18 minutes the
bear stands as a testament to the
dedication and talent of its cast and
crew Jeremy Allen White's meticulous
preparation and training the incredible
working kitchen created on the Sound
Stage and The Chemistry Between the cast
allowed those much needed moments of
comedic relief to shine what are your
favorite moments from the bear
[Music]